[Music]
good morning my name is Todd gage I'm
the product manager for persistent disk
and local SSD I want to thank you all
for joining us here this morning
especially at 9:00 a.m. after a big
party last night
so here's we're here dot to talk about
today we're going to talk a bit about
persistent disk some best practices a
little bit about our future performance
and then cover a whole bunch of new
features which I'm very excited to show
you today so for those of you who've
been going to any other storage sessions
those thus far you've probably seen this
slide it gets a bit more complicated
every year a bit more like an eye chart
every year and so to help you out here's
where we are we're looking in the
storage section under block storage and
we're going to be talking about
persistent disk and Google cloud
platform has three block storage
products local SSD which is physically
attached physically resident in the
machine this is a ephemeral storage if
that machine goes down we don't
guarantee that that data remains however
there's also the highest performance
storage we have because it is physically
resident in the machine we have two
flavors of persistent disk now these are
designed to be durable persistent
storage and the two flavors we have one
backed by standard hard drives and
that's really for cost-effective
high-volume storage and then one backed
by SSD which is for your high
performance storage needs and quickly
talk about just sort of overall PD now
as I said PD is a high performance
durable block storage for any of your
virtual instances either on google
kubernetes engine or Google compute
engine presents itself as a virtual
scuzzy device and it scales from one
gigabyte all the way up to 64 T
persistent disk supports multi reader in
read-only mode which we'll talk about a
bit in a moment
speaks excuse me snapshots which again
we'll cover in a moment and scale again
going from one gig to six
forty what the ability to grow while
that disk is in use and as you've
probably heard throughout this week
security is very very key component of
Google cloud platform and so all of our
data is encrypted at rest automatically
either by a Google encrypted key
encryption keys or your own we see a
couple patterns of common patterns of
behavior with persistent disk this is
the simplest this could be your basic
web server WordPress anything like that
we just have one Volume one virtual
machine another common pattern is a root
disk and then some data this could be
your database instance anything we have
working data again not very complicated
this is where things get to be more
interesting this could be a big compute
workload or you have one data data disc
you put it in read-only mode you shard
out all that work to workers and you
don't actually have to you know multiple
you know multiple record that data you
just have all those instances point at
one one disk and then finally something
again we'll talk about a bit more in a
bit is the ability to synchronously
replicate data across two zones with a
new offering that we're calling regional
persistent disk so persistent disk
snapshots I mentioned a second ago this
snapshots are used for a number of
things one is just basic backup of your
data you know this data is critical to
your business you want to make sure that
you have it around in case of future
need snapshots are a great use for that
disaster recovery you want to insulate
your business against disaster you know
you can take snapshots they're stored in
a GCS multi-regional bucket and that
ensures you against the data loss in any
one zone and then finally disk cloning
snapshots allow you to really quickly
replicate discs across multiple regions
multiple zones and starting it's the
it's the first disk is relatively fast
and every disk after that will be very
very fast now here's a couple examples
of snapshots in use on the Left we have
volume one and you see we're taking
snapshots at T one through T for each of
those snapshot
is point in time but it's also
incremental so you're only storing the
additional data that you need from the
previous snapshot now on the right you
see this user is taking a copy of disk -
oh sorry
copy a volume one at time - and then
also doing disk cloning at the bottom
making three copies of volume one at
time four potentially for use across
three different machines couple of best
practices to go through this morning one
thing I didn't mention earlier but you
might have read on this slide is that
persistent disk gives you maximum
performance without the need for a raid
or striping across multiple volumes
persistent disk performance is
exclusively tied to the disk size so we
give you an allocation of i/o per
gigabyte and bandwidth per gigabyte that
increases linearly up to the bandwidth
cap sorry up up to the caps so unlike
other platforms you may have seen
there's no additional need to add add
volumes for performance also we really
suggest you look at both your i/o size
and cue depths so for high ops workloads
we suggest 16 kilobyte block sizes are
smaller and larger io q depths which
really help performance at those lower
block sizes specifically for high i/o
we suggest a queue depth of one for
every 400 800 I ops now
on the other side on high throughput
workloads we suggest block sizes of 256
K or larger and enabling the read ahead
cache in the OS finally we really
suggest aligning your i/o to 4 K
boundaries what you see on the right is
an example of 6 k writes at the top how
persistent disk sees this in the middle
and then how it's actually written to
the volume on the bottom and what's a
little less apparent is that for every 6
K right you actually up to touch 2
blocks
so you're effectively doing 30% more
disk access for the same amount of
traffic and where if you just aligned
your rights to 4k boundaries you can
save those extra disk accesses and now
very excited to share with you some
announcements starting with performance
performance is the thing that we hear
the most about from our customers it's
consistent in literally every customer
conversation and it's something that
we're always focused on improving as I
said earlier persistent disk comes in
two flavors we have standard persistent
disk back by HDD and SSD persistent disk
and then you can really see the the
stark difference in performance here SSD
doubles the I ops on the right side and
is more than an order of magnitude
faster on reads one thing to note as I
say in the corner here this does require
machines with 32 V CPUs or larger on the
SSD side to achieve these I ops and now
I'm very very excited to pronounce or
announce a 50% improvement in read
performance for PD SSD this increases
our read I ops to 60,000 and our
bandwidth to 1.2 gigabytes now some
lucky few of you may have already seen
this performance in production but if
you haven't don't worry it will be
rolling out to all of the PD SSD over
the next couple of weeks and I'm very
very excited to see people take
advantage of it now this isn't as I said
we're always working on performance and
we're not stopping there so we do have
something in our performance labs that
we're working on and this is a number of
changes kind of baked in together but as
you can see we're getting all the way up
to 100k I ops and 1.6 gigabytes of
bandwidth and the most exciting thing
for us is how that translates into
real-world
real-world performance on the right hand
side you can see we did some read-only
benchmarking against Postgres and
aerospike and saw almost a 30 percent
improvement on Postgres and over a 40
percent improvement
aerospike now as i mentioned in the lab
there's a couple of different changes
going on but as we dug into this it
looks like that performance changes
primarily driven by the AI ops and we're
really excited to get this out
no promises yet but as I said it's
something we're we're actively working
on and now earlier I mentioned regional
persistent disk and now I'd like to talk
about it in a little bit more detail so
regional persistent disk presents itself
as a singular persistent disk to your
virtual machine however on the backend
it is synchronously replicated across
two zones regional persistent disk works
either with google kubernetes engine or
Google compute engine and allows you a
single disk for high availability one
thing to note regional persistent disk
has all the performance of a persistent
disk other than right bandwidth right
bandwidth is halved because you're
writing the the data to two places but
otherwise the performance is exactly the
same so a regional persistent disk
really provides you a building block for
building either disaster recovery
solutions or high availability solutions
depending on what you need for your
business it improves durability and
availability and we've really spent time
building this for mission-critical
applications in fact for any of you that
are using cloud sequel's
high availability configuration that is
backed by a regional persistent disk and
it has been a very successful product
for us this as I note is in beta and
it's available today you can just go to
your instance open a new disc and you
will see something like this so this is
the new UI you can see that replayed
this disk within our region that changes
the zone drop-down and instead of zone
it's now zones and you were able to
select up to two zones in that region so
it's very very straightforward to set up
almost as easy as setting up a normal
person disk but automatically
- replication across these two zones and
now to show you a little bit more about
regional persistent disk in practice I'd
like to introduce saw Dali he's the tech
look tech lead for a google kubernetes
engine storage all right thank you very
much Todd so my name is Sully I'm tech
lead of gke storage and I'm really
really excited about this regional
persistent disk feature let me talk a
little bit about it today so like Todd
mentioned regional persistent disks are
a great building block for building h.a
applications it'll automatically handle
any storage level failures it'll
automatically failover with lower
latency but it'll be invisible to you as
an end user but what happens if you have
VM level failure you have zonal failures
and the VMS become unavailable normally
you'd have an outage until somebody on
your team notices and goes in and
manually moves that workload over it's
nice that you have the replication
across zones but you still require
manual intervention in order to make
your application a che or you could
build custom tooling that'll go ahead
and monitor the the virtual machines
monitor your application and you know do
the do the failover manually but that's
a lot of complicated tooling wouldn't it
be nice if there was something that did
this for you automatically kubernetes
engine google kubernetes engine handles
all of this for you already by a show of
hands how many a few are familiar with
kubernetes that's what I like to see and
how many of you use gke
awesome so with gke we do node level
health monitoring already for you and we
automatically will move your workloads
if we detect that the node is unhealthy
and along with your workloads we'll move
your storage you don't have to do a
thing so the next question is how do you
actually use this in kubernetes if
you're familiar with kubernetes you've
probably already seen the storage class
api object it enables kubernetes cluster
administrators to specify a template for
provisioning new volumes
so when you as an end-user want to use
storage you specify a storage class in
your persistent volume object and a new
volume gets provisioned using that
template so to enable automatic
provisioning of regional persistent
disks all you have to do is add a couple
new parameters to your storage class one
is the replication type to indicate that
you want a regional persistent disk and
the second is zones to indicate which
zones you want your persistent disk to
be replicated in and then kubernetes
will automatically provision a new
regional persistent disk for you and
you'll use it in exactly the same way
you're used to using persistent volumes
in kubernetes today
so now let's take a look at how it's
going to work in practice so imagine you
have two zones and each has a single
zone and you have a workload that's
running on the node in zone one and
replication a replicated disk is
attached to that to that workload but
now zone one suffers some sort of
failure and the node in zone one is no
longer available kubernetes is
automatically going to detect this and
it's going to terminate your app from
the unhealthy zone and prepare it for
moving and it'll automatically detach
the volume from the the node in the
first zone and attach it to the healthy
node in the second zone and move your
workload over as well and your stateful
service basically automatically heals
from a zonal failure without you having
to intervene at all you didn't have to
write custom tooling you didn't have to
do any manual intervention that's the
beauty of regional persistent disks so
regional persistent disks are available
as a beta feature starting with
kubernetes 110 please try it out and let
us know what you think thank you very
much
back to you Todd Thank You sug
[Applause]
so I realized I didn't cover one key
thing about regional persistent disk
which is it is available in both flavors
of persistent disk you can do regional
persistent disk for a standard
persistent disk or SSD persistent disk
depending on your business need and now
I want to talk about regional snapshots
regional snapshots allow users for the
first time to specify the locations that
their snapshots land in as I mentioned
earlier today snapshots automatically
get recorded in a GCS multi-regional
bucket and going forward users will be
able to select whether they wish a
region or multi regional bucket and then
can select any region or multi region
within the Google Network this really
provides users a choice between whether
they want does that insulation against
disaster recovery or the data residency
where you really need to data to stay in
a single location for legal or
regulatory reasons this also for the
first time means that snapshots are
going to begin to charge for network
transit and so there's also a cost
effective play here where if you want I
want to avoid network transit you can
keep those snapshots exactly where the
disc is and all you pay for is the
storage you're paying for today if you
have any interest in this whatsoever
please call email pd interest at
google.com and I'd be very very happy to
share you with you more information
here's an example of what this looks
like in practice I'm gonna highlight the
key features for you here on the left
hand side we see that we're setting up a
regional snapshot and I've selected the
default which is just have the snapshot
reside in the exact same location as the
disk as I said earlier this is a setup
we see fairly commonly for data
residency data locality concerns and/or
to drive cost down on the right you can
see I'm selecting a multi regional
bucket and moving the data to the EU and
this would be again for disaster or if I
know that I need to replicate that disc
multiple times in the EU in the future I
can write that data to the
you once and then replicate locally many
many times again for for cost savings on
the network turns it your snapshot
filter let your snapshot list will also
begin to change and there is a new
column here for location it's the second
column there it just shows you where
these snapshots reside or where the
people you know need snapshot management
tools and this will really help you find
all of your snapshots where based on
location using the filter another
exciting feature for snapshots I'm happy
to talk about is snapshot scheduling
snapshot at scheduling provides a life
cycle management for your snapshots from
creation to deletion you can schedule
per hour by day or by week it supports
snapshot locality and again this is
something that's of interest please
e-mail pd interest at
google.com/analytics kejal and you can
see selected a regional bucket but then
down in the frequency selected every day
at 3 o'clock so this snapshot will kick
off but in that hour once a day and then
all of those snapshots will be deleted
automatically 14 days later in this
instance I'm setting up a weekly
schedule and as you see I'm specifying
the day of the week and then which hour
of that day I want the snapshot created
her snapshot created now what you can't
see is on the bottom of the screen
there's still the auto delete row it
just is off the screen but every
snapshot scheduled includes an auto
deletion policy I'm not going to show
you the hourly schedule today but it's
very much in line with these two however
what I will show you is how you attach a
schedule to a disk now at the top you
select the disk every disk today can
only have one attached schedule however
you can use a schedule for many many
disks so if you know that you have some
data that you want to backup every day
some data you want to backup
every week or month or don't have
monthly yet but it's in the works or out
every hour then you can set up those
schedules at singularly and then attach
that to all the data discs that it
applies to so you don't have to manage
many many schedules so again if you have
any questions about anything that you've
seen today please email PD interest at
google.com
that's for alpha signups questions about
best practices or any other things you
would like to know
[Music]